all right
we are live
so hello everybody
it's nice to see right away in the chat
uh dear paul robbins neil degrade is
there and james flames though who don't
know james flames james is uh is an
artist he's an illustrator he's
illustrated um
several very very popular bands and he's
a really really a great illustrator and
he kind of fell into the symbolic world
and you know interested in in
christianity moving towards orthodoxy
just uh amazing art you can check out
his posters online
and so we've got
how many people have got 10 people
it's kind of nice to uh to have less
people and to be able to engage with the
chat i really enjoyed that last time so
hopefully this time we'll be able to do
that so a few announcements uh to make
uh i'm happy to see that neil is in the
chat
there is a new episode of dirt pool
robin's queen of the night they they put
out the first episode i guess a few
months ago about a month ago and now the
second episode is out it's truly
astounding what neil has been able to do
obviously the music but also the visuals
just the rich
ornamentation and the this kind of rich
feeling of this uh kind of art nouveau
futuristic world very powerful stuff and
the story of course is uh
is starting to appear we're starting to
kind of see what everything is going to
be about the characters are really
interesting so check it out go on their
youtube channel it is there for free
he's doing it um
section by section and uh and once it's
all out then uh then he'll probably be
putting it out some way or another as a
full movie so check it out um
other announcements i don't know i don't
have any announcements everybody knows
what's going on in canada right now i
don't need to announce
it but uh
yeah so yeah we do what we can we do
what we can
and um for those that are following the
gods dog stuff it has been pretty crazy
in terms of realizing hitting the
logistics wall of this thing it took
forever to get the money
we just got the money about i think like
a week and a half ago because it
indiegogo kept telling us there was the
wrong type of account and wrong type of
account and just like three times we had
to go through it and so it's putting
massive delays on everything and so
apologies for everybody what we decided
to do is that for those who bought the
book
we will send everybody a uh the pdf if
you want to get we to be able to read in
advance because i really don't see us
being able to ship this you know within
three months because they're also
telling us that there are massive delays
in
in shipping any kind of shipping that is
uh prints coming from overseas so yeah a
lot of stuff so anyways we'll do what we
can but we're definitely on it as much
as we can beyond it
so here we go everybody i will start
with the website
oh so yeah for those who are watching
this afterwards i've decided to make the
q a uh patron only just because
i want to be able to engage with the
chat i didn't want to have
the super chats anymore because it was
kind of chaotic and too many questions
that we reduce the questions
i have someone who goes through the
questions and kind of tries to reduce
them to a reasonable amount
and uh and then i answer them live with
people on patreon and then after that
people can watch it if they want on uh
on youtube so it's last month we did it
that way and it was great
it was uh it was is much more human
let's say so we'll keep doing it this
way for now
all right so i will start with people
supporting me on paypal on the website
here we go so into the woods asks
hi jonathan several times you've
mentioned the great pitfall of the
scientific worldview that it fails to
include its model of the universe in the
universe
i always feel like i'm on the verge of
understanding what you mean by this
but i'm desperate for a slightly fuller
explanation thanks for
any you can offer and for all you do
um
so uh maybe a good way to
understand this is to maybe think of
just any kind of
scientific theory
so
right uh
assigned a scientist will look at
phenomena or will have an insight and
then we'll try to not to um we'll try to
uh model
the phenomena into a pattern that can be
that can be quantified they can be exp
that can be described and then that can
be predicted and ultimately maybe even
reproduced all right so that's pretty
much what what science is
so they look at phenomena that you can
quantify and they do that now the
problem with that model is that
the the model of how the phenomena
interact with each other
isn't part of the scientific theory
and so the the problem is something like
science is not scientific
because in order for you to do
scientific work
you you have to have the model and then
you apply it but the model itself
isn't part of the thing you're applying
it to it can't be right it has to
somehow be above it has to be a pattern
that's why in matsuri in his book he
talks about how even in science there is
this meeting of heaven and earth where
there's invisible
patterns invisible principles and then
there is
uh potential and there's a
you know there's manifestation or
there's quantifiable things facts out
there multiplicity of facts and and
the role of consciousness the role of
the person the role of intelligence is
to join them together and so
that is what so in a way that's why even
in maturity's book he talks about how
even science is ultimately symbolic
because that's what we're trying to do
now the the reason why we insist on this
so much is that
one of the things that science has done
not science per se but
certain brand of scientists what it has
done is that it has tended to
to um to kind of denigrate the
the pattern part of the process and to
see it to see in in our human
interactions to see the the the pattern
part or the story part or all of these
things as superstitious as an overlay as
something that is on top of phenomena
what's really important is the stuff
we're studying here but this stuff first
of all directly in the theory it is
due to uh
a
an invisible pattern but then even on a
bigger scale the fact that you're even
interested in the thing you're studying
in the first place is due to an even
bigger pattern which is the the fact of
humanity itself the fact of the the
possibility of human consciousness the
possibility of attention of interest all
of these things which make us focus on
certain things rather than others
precedes the the scientific endeavor so
that's why you know i say things like
science is embedded in religion or
science is embedded in if you if you
people if you get if that if the name
religion gets you annoyed ultimately i
think it's true but you could say
something like science is embedded in in
the social science is embedded in
in the capacity for intelligence
or science is embedded in
human existence right you could say it
that way
maybe it'd be easier for people to
understand it that way that we we study
certain things for certain reasons and
those reasons are not
scientific right
hopefully that that makes sense i hope
that that's explainable
um all right so david flores asks
what is the symbolism of repairing teeth
what is the symbolism of repairing teeth
um
so
okay this is the way that i i see it
so teeth
teeth have something to do with the
capacity to uh
properly engage with the world or
something like to be able to integrate
the world
so teeth are the the primary tool by
which we
we eat you know they're the primary tool
by which we take the world outside and
we integrate it inside and so when you
lose your teeth or when you your teeth
are broken
you are not you're not properly capable
of engaging with the outside potential
so the teeth are there to break that
stuff down and then make it into
into you basically so that's probably
why too like
i think a lot of people have these
dreams like when you're really stressed
out and you're losing control
and you feel like things are out of your
control that you can dream that you're
losing your teeth that's one of the
things people dream of quite a bit i
think you know you can dream like
there's something wrong with your teeth
like all of a sudden you put your hand
in and like your tooth falls out
something like that it has to do with a
kind of lack of a breakdown of your
capacity to control things you know
you're feeling helpless feeling out of
con like things are out of control um so
maybe that makes sense
at least that's my this is really my own
intuition i've never read anything on it
um i'm sure i'm sure it's like the kind
of union people would have definitely
have a theory on teeth
all right so cormac jones asked hi
jonathan i think i heard you say once
that before you became interested in the
symbolic mythology is a popular cinema
when you were younger you favored more
idiosyncratic art cinema what kind of
movies or filmmakers did you favor then
and what is your opinion of them now
uh were there any that were particularly
formative
um and so
it's interesting because there was like
a weird coincidence i guess when i was a
teenager
which is that when i was kind of coming
into the moment of
that moment in your late teens and early
20s when you are
can i say this you're discovering
intelligence you're discovering culture
all of these things that's when the uh
the the berlin wall fell
and so
after the berlin wall fail all these um
all these uh movie directors all of a
sudden that weren't so much
that weren't as much on our radar you
could say kind of flooded into our
cultural space and so that was really
the time when i when i was discovering
it so i really remember for example um
uh what's his name kieslowski
uh who did the the the
who did the uh red white and blue
trilogy he also did a whole series on
the ten commandments i remember reeling
getting a lot of from from those uh from
those also uh
nikita uh what's his name
what's his name um
mikalkov nikita mikalkov he's the
russian director i remember seeing his
stuff but i also like i also like woody
allen and obviously it was also
you know when i was i think like 20 is
when pulp fiction came out and so
that plunged us into a whole world of uh
like quentin tarantino and then
japanese films and that kind of stuff so
so those were the people i guess that
inter that influenced me the most
um
i would say there's something about
kievslowski which i
which i
keep there was something
there there was something a little
arbitrary in his use of symbolism but
there was this desire to kind of create
connections let's say his series on the
ten commandments to create narratives
that are embedded within a commandment
that aren't necessarily moralistic but
are just an exploration of the
consequence of breaking it or the desire
to keep it or you know it was this like
loose association with the commandment
and there were some interesting things
there i think um
and so um the same with mikalkov
did his his movie uh what they called
forget because i saw it in french
something about the sun i think it was a
burning sun or something forget what the
name of the movie was
it was an amazing movie about uh the
rise of communism and like how the um
the even the revolutionaries then got
swept up and got taken up by the next
generation who were resentful uh about
their their success um
yeah so he he made some pretty amazing
movies
so uh so yeah so those were the ones i
would say
and i would say they did have some
influence on me i don't know how
how enduring that their relationship was
but it was there
all right brother james as do you know
any artists or iconographers who create
icons directly in the digital realm for
instance using wacom cintiq in photoshop
another drawing software and then
printing them and mounting them
and then getting them blessed is that
even a thing or do digitally printed
icons always have to originate from a
photo scan or a hand painted icon in
real life inside question do you
personally feel about digitally printed
icons either one source from photo scans
or real life originals or ones created
directly in the digital realm
and so
maybe i can answer you this way
um
i have never purchased a uh
a
mechanically printed icon and so i have
some
that is i have some that were either
given to me or
you know in books and stuff but i have
never purchased a uh a um an icon that
was printed off a uh
an online um
when i was printed from a jpeg or
something like that so
i think
and it's funny people are gonna find it
funny some people might not understand
because like here's jonathan doing nfts
and
and uh doing t-shirts and doing all this
stuff but he doesn't want to have
printed icons then it has to do with
hierarchy folks it there is really is
there's a power in hierarchy which is
that
i believe that there is a hierarchy of
materiality if you want to look at it i
wrote um i wrote an article a long time
ago you can find it on the orthodox
article i think it's called the
symbolism
i forget what it was called
it was something about it was
it was about the hierarchy of materials
and how in the the description of the
the temple or the tabernacle there's
actually a hierarchy of materials that
is that certain metals like gold is in
is mostly in the um in the holy of
holies and then with some silver and
then if you move out then there's bronze
and then there's a stone altar so
there's this like hierarchy of
materiality which is there in the
construction of the temple but also
represent manifest itself in the in the
hierarchy of the the statue in the
vision of daniel with the golden head
you know the silver uh silver torso i
think is that what it is the silver arms
and the uh the bronze torso and then the
the
legs of iron and the feet of iron and
clay are the toes of iron and clay um
so this hierarchy is why we say why the
ancients used to say golden age silver
age bronze age you know that it was like
this declining thing and so that's what
i think about uh art in general and so i
believe that when we create things for
the church the materiality of the object
first of all is important because we are
incar there's an incarnational aspect to
the liturgical arts that is they're
supposed to participate in the in the
the space and so they have to be born
out of that
material space you know and so i do
believe icon should be made
should be made ultimately by hand
and should be made with noble materials
and so wood natural materials gold
natural pigments that is the ideal now i
am not saying that icons painted with
acrylic or that icons even icons that
are printed from uh from a jpeg or that
you buy a print of i'm not saying they
are not icons and they cannot function
at all as icons that is that is not the
case but i do see it more like as this
organic hierarchy that there's a need to
stay attached to these higher materials
in the sacred space because if we're not
careful and we we we fill up all our
churches with with uh icon that are
mechanically reproduced it will have an
effect on our
we are the way that we are in the world
the way that we engage with the world
the way that we perceive the art artist
the artisan and their function in the in
the sacred world all of these things i
think need to kind of be kept in place
and so if you look at the way that my
art functions i tend to i tend to really
do believe in this hierarchy so if i
make something for churches i try to
have the noble materials the highest
form materials gold stone uh you know
semi-precious stones uh
wood and then moving down
into
popular arts and as i move towards
popular arts and i'm willing to have
more mechanically reproduced arts even
if there's something there's even on the
t-shirts for example where i do use
images of holy images of protection that
are guardians and
you know um
angels that are killing monsters saying
george all these images that are more
of the edge of the protective edge you
could say and then ultimately for god's
dog because of what god's dog is and
because it is about monstrosity and
about hybrid hybridization and about the
strange then
i i felt like it would was completely
appropriate to go all the way into the
digital and into uh nfts um and so
that's the way i understand the
material hierarchy you could say so um
yeah i mean people could argue with me
but but for sure i'm not doing things
arbitrarily that's for sure i've decided
to do things this way uh because i want
to participate in the fullness of the of
the the hierarchy let's say without
without saying that the technological
world is evil but understanding that the
technological world has to be in its
proper place
[Music]
all right so jay grubb asks what is the
symbolism of bigfoot
i mean
okay so
it's not it's not proper to to answer
the symbolism of a bigfoot that it's
maybe a good idea to understand that the
symbolism of cryptids in general and so
all these cryptids that people see
whether it's bigfoot whether it's
these different wolf men that exist um
uh in different uh legends in america
where whether it's also other types of
cryptids other other other types of
strange animals you know whatever the
jackalope or whatever kind of cryptid
that you can imagine werewolves and all
the stuff they all have to do with the
problem of the limit they all have to do
with the the problem of
of what how the margin presents itself
and so the margin always presents itself
as hybrid as mixture but not just that
it also and it's also aliens by the way
if you want the the the article that i
wrote the last article that i wrote in
the gods dog secrets book is going to be
about this um for those who are
interested so the
it's also the way they actually manifest
themselves to us so they're always not
completely within the coherence of the
world so bigfoot is always hearsay it's
always a legend it's always someone who
saw bigfoot furtively you know nobody
has an actual just nope like there are
no nobody has you know sat down with
bigfoot talked to him you know had a you
know or shot him or has has a
some kind of completely uh
let's say um tangible proof of bigfoot's
existence because bigfoot is this
in-between space he's part of it and all
like all these other types of creatures
just like aliens and all these kind of
cryptid and so they're all these images
of how on the edge there's a breakdown
of identity um but that breakdown of it
identity happens in the very way we talk
about it not just in the monsters
themselves but in the fact that they're
unexplained phenomena right it's all
unexplained so the idea that something
is unexplained
is means it's something that doesn't
have an identity that has a hybrid
marginal identity so uh
so yeah so
so the question is does bigfoot exist in
the way that santa exists i would say
that for sure bigfoot exists exists less
than santa if you want to say it that
way or he exists like he's a monster
bigfoot's a monster santa's not a
monster and monsters uh you know just
like dragons exist too right they they
are on they are this hybrid
possibility on the edge of being and so
yeah
so josh the mover says why do the
simpsons keep accurately predicting
everything that happens
um
i don't know i have no idea i mean i i
think that
but this might this might uh
frustrate some people because
so i i do think that artists are
somewhat prophetic just in the fact that
they're making up stories
i think that the place they
the the place where they get the stories
that they make up um
that intuition
part of it is is something like you
could say it's something like uh
early pattern detection right so if you
think about it just in terms of kind of
evolutionary terms why would people make
up stories you know why would they do
that and it has to do with the idea of
what is it that jordan peterson says
something like die die in your stories
right so you don't die in real life so
you you create stories in which you
experiment with reality uh so that you
don't have to go through all the
possibilities of being
and you don't have to experience the
negative things that other people have
experienced but i think there's also
probably something like that but also a
kind of early detection pattern
capacity that we have which is that some
people are capable of intuiting what is
just over the hill
and then
let's say making stories out of it so
that explains a lot of stuff i mean
there's not just it's not just in the
simpsons
if you could if i could make a list for
you of how many series and even movies
just before the pandemic were pretty
much laying out what the pandemic was
going to be about you know and so i mean
it's pretty amazing so some people see
direction in that some people see you
know
this a kind of kind of centralized
programming which i mean maybe it's
possible that that's part of it i don't
know it's possible there are people with
a lot of money and a lot of power who
are trying to um who are trying to
direct how the future is going to happen
that wouldn't be completely insane but
you also don't necessarily need to have
that for it to happen that way you know
because i do think that storytelling is
in part a kind of early predictive
modeling you could say of
you know in order to help us prepare for
that which is that we intuit to be over
the
over the hill because it
how can i say this it's like people
people always think it's weird that you
can predict the future but it's like you
can always predict
everybody predicts the future all the
time there's nothing weird about
predicting the future it's just that
we predict the future at smaller scales
right it's like i know that at this
month it's going to be cold and i know
that this month it's going to be warm
pretty much it's not 100 but i know
these things and i know that you know i
know that if if i watch my kids poking
at each other
if nothing happens there's they're going
to start fighting and kids know that
about their parents too they know that
if mom is sitting with their arms
crossed or whatever and dad is her dad
is doing this that it means will
probably be a fight tonight
it's like and and so i think that there
are things like that for society where
societies are let's say very sensitive
people in societies can intuit by the
patterns that are happening now
what's going to
happen
um
and sometimes it can be pretty uh pretty
precise actually
and sometimes it's vague and uh you know
i don't find any of that very weird at
all i don't think there's no they don't
need a hocus pocus and magic to believe
that it's possible to intuit and to
predict some some aspects of the future
um
neil says cryptozoology was my dream
dream job as a child you can still do it
neil you can still do it go find go find
nessie or whatever the name of it is
um
all right
and so here we go let's kee i need to
keep it continue to pay attention to the
chat that was the whole point of this
right
all right eric salander asks hi jonathan
thanks for a great conversation i would
like to know more about the symbolism of
iron thor is said to need a pair of iron
gloves to use his hammer and also when
handling a lightning bolt there's also a
giant test said to dwell in an iron
forest
as always thank you so much and remember
god is still good so thanks eric yes god
is still good
um
so i really got i already talked about
it strangely enough and that when i
talked about the hierarchy of uh of
materiality and so a good way to
understand the hierarchy of materiality
is to understand especially in terms of
the metals
is to understand that
the the higher on the hierarchy of the
metal is
the the more precious it is that is the
least of it there is the more um
let's say incorruptible it is
right that is it it lasts longer
um
you could also say that the more that
it's related to light that it has
something to do with a certain amount of
light in it
um
and then the lower something is but then
it's also softer
it also has less
power in the physical sense so it has a
lot of meaning it's precious
it's it's full of light and it's uh and
it's
uh but it can't it it's not strong it's
not powerful so now the lower you go on
the and the the hierarchy materiality of
metals you know you move towards silver
which is also very light but tends to
tarnish and then you have bronze which
is darker and is stronger than silver
stronger than gold but tends to also
corrode but not that much and then you
move down to iron then when you get to
iron
then you have
the metal that is
the strongest
but is also the most fragile in the
sense that it that it rusts and it and
it can it can just vanish it if if you
leave it out into in the you know the
in the rain and the sun and so
there's an iron is plentiful like
there's plenty and plenty of iron and
it's much stronger
um
but it's also more
fragile it's less malleable than gold or
silver right it's hard to make a ring
out of out of uh out of iron it's easy
to make a ring out of gold and so
that's the material hierarchy and so in
for example in the vision of daniel on
the bottom of that then you have
something like
the
hybridization where you have iron mixed
with clay so think of it i always think
that iron mix with clay for us is
something like plastic right something
like plastic which is
uber plentiful
and is extremely fragile uh but is also
like let's say
fills up like fills up the filling up
the ocean right so plastic is filling up
the ocean that's the last uh thing we
can also understand in terms of like uh
in terms of like if you want to so for
example like if think of it like
if you if you take a precious metal and
then you make a coin out of it then what
the the the government will want to do
is they might want to debase the coin so
they'll add another metal they'll
hybridize it you know and when they
hybridize it then they make more but
they make it less precious and so
you can think about all that so the
reason why
um
there's a relationship between war and
iron is super important you see that
in scripture because often you know you
get you get these peoples that have iron
chariots and these people with iron
chariots they're like they're the
warriors right they're the they're
dangerous because they have these these
powerful iron uh chariots
um
and so that would that would be why
giants would live in an iron forest for
example or that you know thor would need
iron gloves to use his hammer
all right
so
all right let's see what do we got here
all right
okay so bogdan asked hi jonathan how do
you distinguish between an enchanted
world in the medieval christian sense
and a sort of animus worldview which
acknowledges the spiritual aspect of all
things but is not christian is it purely
a matter of having the proper hierarchy
with god at the top or is there
something more to it thanks for all your
work and so i do believe that it is a
the difference is what you said i think
the difference is
that
in the truly kind of the real the true
cosmology is to have
the you can have a hierarchy of
intermediary beings but they are
ultimately all dependent on the one on
on god
and uh and then they
you know their powers or their authority
flows from the the one and so
in the different mythologies you see
that at some point in many of the
mythologies there is a revolution
in the heavens there are some gods that
try to
to get power from the higher god
and that's when
different paganisms appear and then
that's when animism i think starts to
appear and so on you know actually
contrary to the belief i think of a lot
of the anthropologists and all that kind
of stuff i i because anthropologists
look at animist societies now and they
think that somehow those animist
societies their reflection of what was
there you know uh at the origin
you know
okay i don't know how you say that but i
i honestly think that it's probably the
opposite i do i probably i think that
there's probably a breakdown that
happened at some point where the
normal hierarchy broke down and then
then all these different gods and you
can see that in stories like the story
of babel and and things like that where
the the different gods kind of
spread out
um and then people started worshiping
and so the problem with animism is that
you're you become slaves you either try
to weaponize the principality but you
try to control it or it controls you and
it's this just this this relationship of
control which is that you try to control
the the the forces of this space or of
this area by propitiating it by by let's
say trapping it in some magical way and
then using it to your advantage um or
you are kind of a slave to this thing
and you have to you have to propitiate
it in the sense of stopping it from
hurting you right you have to keep it at
bay so that it doesn't hurt you and so
that is the difference i think between
um and so and so this this kind of
traditional hierarchy is not it's there
obviously in christianity but it's there
in other traditions it's not just there
you know you see it in in uh kind of
advice
vedanta uh hinduism you really do see
something like that and you see it in in
zoryastrianism and you see it in
in um
you know there are some there are some
moments where other cultures where you
can see these types of this type of
hierarchy so the idea that the idea that
there's only um
that judaism and christianity and islam
are the only place where this kind of
structure exists i don't think that's
true
i do think that for sure christianity
because it reveals
it reveals uh love as the source of of
all things and it also reveals
self-sacrifice as the mode of being that
is the most proper to to the to uh to
being in relationship with the divine
you know i think it's the best but it's
not the only one that has something like
that
all right so a popper asks
what's the difference between thoughts
ideas categories and spiritual beings
angels powers principalities both in how
we engage with them hoes give them body
and their impact on who we are our
identity
so
so there's there's a first of all in
yourself so maybe a good way to see it
would be to understand the fractal
nature of of reality you could say and
so
there are certain of those things which
are inside you
and so thoughts ideas uh
or inside humanity you could say
but also inside you thoughts ideas
categories all of this is within you and
these things they they have a more
active role than sometimes you might
think they play out as programs you're
not
you're not as much in control of those
things as you
wish you were let's say
uh ultimately the idea would be to have
you as a as a centralized being and no
matter how you phrase it in a way it
doesn't even matter like a lot of these
categories when people ask them people
have souls and all this stuff like i
mean yes but
you understand it is what you need to do
if you want to know what it's about and
so that there's that there's something
which binds you all together right that
holds all of this multiplicity of
thoughts categories uh
let's say thoughts and ideas first of
all right that's first that's mostly
let's say within you um
and then there are
spiritual beings which are something
like that but they're more active and
they're more cosmic that is they are the
they are the cosmic aspect so as you as
a microcosm have you could say you have
these little
desires and thoughts and gods these
little gods in you
want to understand that way you have
these little thoughts and
and ideas and uh
and desires and they're all inside you
and they're all fighting and they're all
trying to have power and they're trying
to get power over the other they're
trying to get your attention and they're
doing all these things they're trying to
get all your resources they're doing all
of this and then hopefully you can align
them together so that they are
they flow naturally from your your your
identity you could say and then in the
world then there's a version of that but
now it's a cosmic version so there are
principalities which act in the world
which bind
groups together which bind which bind
all these things
all these the way in which the world
manifests itself together and ultimately
they they when they're not let's say
brought together
under god then they tend to create
conflict and to create
to create conflict
so the mystery which is maybe difficult
the mystery is that in a certain manner
all of this
ultimately is resolved by
you could say man or by the incarnation
and so the perfect union of god and man
is the is actually the place where all
of this resolves and so there's a
certain man in which although these
these spiritual beings which are more
cosmic
uh are
have a difference on a different scale
than your thoughts and your desires and
your ideas
uh
not ultimately they are
let's say
ultimately they should also be subject
to man man with a capital m right the
incarnate man and the manner in which we
participate in
that as human beings
um
hopefully that makes sense now
what's what's interesting is you can see
that there's a relationship between
the cosmic beings and you inside and so
that's why
you could say something like that's why
demons affect you
because the demon
is a demon of pride or as a demon of
this
which is also inside you as an invisible
desire an invisible thought pattern or
an invisible motivation that you have
and then those are connected
to the cosmic version of that
so all the imagery of like a demon
oppressing you or a demon uh possessing
you all of these things are because
there's a direct relationship between
the way you are made and the way the
cosmos is made and so sometimes you can
read text and it almost seems confusing
it's like is it this person's sins
desires or is it a demon that's
oppressing them and ultimately there's a
way in which it's it's always both at
the same time uh because there's a
there's a cosmic reflection
that when you become a slave of a
passion or of a thought pattern or
something in you
you are ultimately participating in the
existence of that in the bigger world
right so if you're
it's not it's not magical it's not it's
not it's it's it's really very basic
it's like if if you
are tempted to be greedy and then you
give into that thought pattern and that
desire and then you you act in greed
right
then
that will connect
that is what will make greed grow in the
world and there'll be more greed in the
world so you're feeding
this demon so that the world itself will
become greedier because the world
doesn't become greedier unless people
become greedier
and but you could also say like if the
world becomes greedier then people will
also become greedier there's like a
there's a top down and a bottom-up
relationship um
and so i think that that's the best way
to understand it and so now in terms of
categories
categories seem a little less active but
they're nonetheless active to a certain
extent
it's not exactly in the way that you
would think but
you can understand that
so it's like let's say i have a category
so i i have a a pen okay
and so this pen is a is a category it's
an invisible pattern
but this pen has subcategories right
we've talked about this many times
now
this is going to sound weird to you but
the the
the category of the pen
is actively holding together
the subcategories which which which
make it a pen
this is ultimately happening through us
that it's happening through men like i
told you ultimately all these patterns
are actually ultimately bound to
to to man but there's something less
neutral about let's say the man in which
categories bind other categories to them
the man in which categories participate
in higher categories as well there's a
judgment right there there's a there's a
judgment which is happening the pen is
judging whether or not
uh
this or that can be part of it and it's
judging it by its purpose by its
teleology right if i make uh if i make a
a pen with a
with a
snowball right it's it's going to not
the pen is going to reject it the pen is
going to judge it and it won't be a good
pen
um and and like i said we're not
excluded from that process we're part of
that process but we could nonetheless
describe the world that way and it's
completely uh it's completely coherent
it's actually i think more coherent than
than uh if we describe it in another way
um
all
right
i think that's good enough
okay so
pneumonia says esau and david's physical
description are very similar in
scripture both are described as ready
yet one is a hunter and the other is a
shepherd what is the symbolism of their
physical descriptions with their
contrasting treatments of animals um
you did definitely caught on to
something there
that is both david and esau are red
that's very important that is um
uh
there's a connection between david and
esau you could say
one of the reasons
why
david
one of the reasons why
david is
close to the messiah or that david is
one of the only persons described as the
messiah in scripture
is because
he is one of the characters that is
that is the closest to
being able to reincorporate
esau is maybe a good way to understand
that
there are certain characters in
scripture that try to reconcile esau but
they don't
succeed
um
you know like like samson for example
uh but not totally succeed but david
comes closer and ultimately christ is
the one who succeeds in uh
enjoining uh david and esau you know and
so if you if you want the idea of a
hunter and a shepherd it's a little
harder to see because we have to expand
the definition of hunter to a fisherman
so fisherman and shepherd
the one who gets the fish
brings them in integrates them and then
the one who actually also cares for the
sheep that's christ is both uh fisher
men and a shepherd so
hopefully that helps all right
all right kulak
asks hello jonathan
what are your thoughts on the apparent
pattern of the outsider from the minor
realm coming to rule great empires
during time of crisis often with violent
consequences
examples are napoleon the corsican
hitler the austrian style and the
georgian
is this pattern a fallen form of the
stone of the stone builders rejecting
rejected becoming the cornerstone
and in this way is it a kind of
antichrist praying for you and your
family up in quebec and so
um
so okay
this is a little tricky so
let's think of it in practical terms
right let's take it into practical terms
so you have uh you have
groups that are fighting say you have a
um
a nation that isn't holding well
together that is kind of falling apart
and fighting and infighting and so it's
fighting so much
that
no one of the groups that are
represented in the fight
could unify them
how could they right they're too much
they're too
much part of the fight
and so
in this sense this is why in in these
types of situations that the stranger or
the the one who comes from the outside
can come in
and
is able to go from the last to the first
by
um
recapturing the
the uh the potential that is fragmenting
you know and so
that's what is happening there um
and so that is definitely a way that can
happen now it can happen
for ill
and it can happen for good it it can
happen either way and so it can be an
image of antichrist um
but it can also be an image of christ
himself you know
so you can understand something like
that's what christ was to the roman
empire right and so
so i think it just depends on what the
how that pattern plays out and so
that pattern could play out as a form of
as a place where it actually brings the
this this identity to cease existing you
know because the outsider comes in
captures the potential and then turns it
into
something else uh completely but there's
also a way in which that can also be a
kind of a kind of preservation it's also
possible that
that happens and then it kind of
preserves and so
i think that this is why
you know understanding this can maybe
help you understand some of some some
stranger symbolism like you know if you
think of alexander the great for example
like why are the legends of alexander
the great that he was
you know the son of a
of an egyptian priest pretending to be
an egyptian god or something like that
you know why
why is it that king arthur is the
bastard son of pendragon you know and
there's trickery involved and there's
all this stuff there's a sense in which
the the the character that brings things
together is
is uh
can have some of that in in him
um
yeah
but like i said it's not necessarily it
does it's not always for the for the
good but it definitely can be for the
good i do definitely believe that in the
case of christ it was for the for the
good
all right scotty says what is a good
story for understanding the pattern of
prophecy or prediction the good
and the bad
um i don't know i don't know i i i'd
have to think about it that's too much
on the top of my head
a good story for understanding the pro
the pattern of prophecy or prediction
the good and the bad
um
how do you think about it i might not be
able to answer by the end of this but
i'll think about it
so joel g caesar asked what is the
symbolism of killing 1 000 men with a
donkey's job
uh
yeah that's what we're talking about
he's we're going to talk about samson
are we um
so yeah so that's what a donkey so the
donkey is a
is an impure animal
and the donkey is also a
a beast of burden
um
and so
killing killing and your enemies with
the the donkey's jawbone it's something
like capturing the power of the
of impurity you're capturing the power
of the margin and using it against
against your enemy you know and so
because the the
it's funny because this is actually
related this is going to sound weird to
a lot of people
but this is actually related to the
speaking uh donkey in the story of
balaam in the in so in this the story of
the speaking donkey of balaam there's a
way in which
the uh
the the power of this margin is made to
speak like the power of the impure and
the bird of
it is made to speak in order to
preserve
the preserve balum preserve balum from
being judged uh and in this case it's
something like the opposite of that
where but similar in the sense that it's
it's like wielding the power
of the impure and the uh
and the job and the the
and chaos in order to
destroy your enemy
you know um but
all of samson's story is always about
this it's always about the same thing
it's
right it's it's about this you know and
and the power of this you trying to use
the power of this
you know like mature talks about in his
book so it's finding finding honey in
the carcass of a dead lion so
killing a thousand men with a donkey
jawbone is actually the same
symbolically as finding uh honey
in the the body of it of a deadline
you know
i always feel like i'm not making it
clear when i stay in the analogy world
but at least for now that's as close as
it's as it's gonna get
all right and so subscribe star listen
watch subscribe star alright
so
why jacket asks what is the symbolism of
cancer and do you think that cancer is
random or the luck of the draw so to
speak or is the manifestation of
something bigger in a person's life do
you think the particular type of cancer
is also meaningful
i e leukemia versus ovarian
um man
so i don't i don't think it's impossible
for
diseases to have meaning i think that
certain diseases
i wouldn't i wouldn't link it to always
to a like a person
but i think in in just in terms of a
general culture i think that diseases
can have
a um
can have a a meaning
in terms of what's going on let's say in
the in the social sphere and so i kind
of joke a little bit that um
you know covet is the opposite of aids
you could say it's like
you know
it's the it's the end code is the end of
the carnival right because covet is
is uh is
has something to do with
an excessive immunity reaction
and so people
die from the immune reaction to covid
rather than the disease itself it seems
which is why
at least in my understanding which is
why there's so many a lot of uh vaccine
seems to be causing some of the same
effects to some people than that the
disease is causing because it's actually
your immune system which is which is
called making you sick ultimately uh
whereas aids was the opposite of that
aids was a breakdown of the immune
system right it's like open to
everything i'm it's like their body
becomes open to anything and in cobit
it's like the body closes down and it
starts to actually destroy itself by
being closed down so it seems like these
things have meaning and i think that for
sure uh
i think that cancer in general is
something like a
a breakdown through
pride or breakdown through not to
the body not being fully aligned with
itself and so certain parts of the body
uh try to preserve
try to propagate and preserve themselves
at the expense of others and end up
killing
the the person by trying to just
self-perpetuate and try to
to make it to make itself like a kind of
weird parasitical thing within your own
body where certain cells don't want to
die
and they they they they're not willing
to die they just want to to continue to
live and to propagate themselves
until uh
until you die so i think that's
meaningful but i don't necessarily
i don't necessarily think that uh
it has it's not necessarily attributed
to the individual i think who has the
disease you know i think ultimately
christ
gives us the most powerful
vision of that which is that
as christians at least the purpose of
disease in our life
is to manifest the glory of god
um whether we are healed
miraculously like some it happens to
some people or whether we
manifest god in our
dying and that really happens you know
you see people the way that they deal
with disease my cousin who's my best
friend died
uh last year um by 2020 actually sorry
and
and he and he uh and the way he died was
amazing like he was transfigured because
he died with so much uh
so much dignity and so much peace and
so i think that that that's really the
the ultimate meaning that disease can
have
as christians at least that's how we
should that's how we should deal with
disease
is to understand that it's it should be
transformed or flipped into
glory um by the way we
by the way we deal with it
all right so
is there anything interesting going on
in this
uh
in this chat here hmm not sure
all right it was cute sorry guys in the
chat it's like i'm looking for questions
in the chat i don't see any usually
people ask questions to chat i guess now
they've all asked questions in the uh
the q a so they don't have to ask
questions in the chat all right
all right lisa parrott says nothing
interesting is going on so xrd says hi
jonathan i saw an article which revealed
that
since 2005 january 6 is the day with the
most most deaths on average any thought
on that
ah no i have to think about it i mean
january 6 is is interesting because it's
isn't january 6 uh the last day of
christmas right
it's the january 6th is the uh is
epiphany so
you can if it's a if you understand it's
the last day of christmas or the the
last day of
uh
of foolery or fooling let's say
maybe i don't have to think about it
everything about it
says i asked one i don't see it where's
your question we need to ask it again
all right keenan so let's go to patreon
now here we go so keenan wang asks what
relationship do you see between frodo
showing goal of mercy
to be betrayed and jesus choosing
jesus judas as a disciple
huh interesting
i never thought about that
i mean it's interesting it's interesting
because you could say
i mean at least in the i don't know if
there's a relationship between judas um
[Music]
judas
and christ but for sure it's interesting
in the sense that golem is the one who
ultimately ends up destroying the ring
despite himself and so
frodo showing mercy to golem
ends up
being the me although
seemingly unwise at the time ends up
being the mechanism by which the ring
ends up being destroyed to the judgment
of golem but nonetheless
um so i think that's definitely
interesting to think about
that'd be definitely interesting to
think about
so you could you could kind of see it
that way you could see that
you know to the judgment of judas
uh you know christ knew that he had to
be to die and so he chose judas um and
gathered him in and then
judas betrayed christ to his own
judgment but ultimately to the salvation
of all like so it's like golem wasn't
acting virtuously when he tried to
snatch the ring from frodo at the last
minute um
he was being extremely selfish and self
interested but he nonetheless
nonetheless brought about salvation
despite him and i think that's something
that is true about judaism as well so
yeah actually you're right it's good
good good um observation there
all right so there you go see what is
here
gerardo in the uh
the chat asked concerning our
sanctification how true is it that we
are supposed to choose christ instead of
good or evil
i read that from a protestant book which
makes it suspicious but it sounds kind
of orthodox um
i mean i i'm not sure what that totally
means like
i can understand what it means in the
sense that christ
is beyond petty morality that's for sure
and that the things that christ ask us
to do are beyond the
or beyond the kind of moralism or the
kind of legalism that you could engage
with so in that sense i think that it's
true
um
but ultimately that ends up being a
higher good is the best way to
understand that as
well um
all right one more questions from bob
briggs john fisher you're the ronin what
do you mean if you can say on state
control media lol
all right so everybody saw that i
changed my my uh
my uh profile picture for a ronin um a
version of a print that i that i
actually acquired last year
um and i i've been writing year of the
ronin it's just because
this year i'm going to start very soon
by the way i'll show you next probably
one of my next videos is going to be
about
uh
the role of the misfit in a tyrannical
system and and we're going to talk about
king david and how he
how he deals with king saul who tries to
uh
who who tries to jab him and pin him to
the wall let's say
and so we'll look at that and we'll look
at other stuff like that and so i think
that that's what's going to
happen and and also because
in my case
you know we're moving into illegitimate
illegitimacy at some point you know
uh the way that things are going here
yeah there's gonna be some tough choices
to make very soon all right
so go back into the back into the
patreon question chase and lindsey hey
jonathan before the modern age why were
cats associated with demons i've heard
this belief led to a mass killing of
cats during the black death outbreaks
what kind of symbolism is behind your
beings killing cats during these
outbreaks when letting them live might
have helped prevent the loss of life are
these two facts about cats just a
fabrication of modern times thank you
for any insight as usual i would say for
sure i'd be very suspicious of all the
things people say about the middle ages
i don't know if that's true there's so
much nonsense people have said about the
middle ages not just the middle ages
just so much that no one
it's like for example when people tell
you that that that the medieval didn't
bathe all this kind of nonsense it's all
made up none of it is true it's just
it's just complete nonsense people see
anecdotal things in some text and then
they make it into a rule about everybody
it's
what people say about the middle ages is
used mostly aguas so so i'm not really
sure that that's true
that that they would be killing cats
maybe they did i don't know there is
such a thing also as panic you know and
so
so
the kind of things that people did in
the plague let's say during panic the
kind of desire to scapegoat and desire
to find someone responsible and the
desire to find something to do in order
to avoid getting disease is something
which we will look back on this
this situation and we will do the same
look at those silly people thinking
they're going to stop a disease with
this and that when
you know and so i would say
yeah i don't know i don't know
all right
but if you want to know why the early
moderns might have said that about the
medievals it was probably had to do with
the fact that there's a there's our the
legends of the which is familiar it
probably has something to do with that
which is the notion that that witches
would would would have a an animal that
was something like
a projection of them that they would
project their spirit into this animal
that they could control it that it was a
a kind of
externalization of that of the witches
being and so i could i could imagine
that that's why stories like that would
have appeared which is that the with the
cat because a cat is a
is a is an animal which is uh it's a
domestic animal and it's a
it's a domestic animal which is sneaky
and hides and and you know does all
these things that that it would have
that people would think of stories like
this so
that's the best i'm gonna do with that
so douglas horde says keep the ethiopian
vids coming i'm doing it i'm supposed to
have an interview with uh with deacon
enoch that i talked about i talked with
him on my channel i'm supposed to be on
his channel at some point but i don't
know when that is should be soon i hope
it soon um
all right m shaffer asked so i recently
watched you say that fractalization is
tied
to death
also it seems to me attention itself is
a kind of death giving out of yourself
for giving over yourself um
but in order for creation to be good
wouldn't there have to be a
disintegrative attending
or sin and non-disintegranting attending
or love or is creation the death of god
whoa dude
that went that went fast
our sin and creation equal vocal sincere
question for a roman catholic
um
all right so
okay so yeah so breakdown is related to
death okay so let's let's let's look at
it this way and so
all right so exteriorization and
breakdown and and and and
multiplication and fragmentation is
related to death but it's also related
to other things it's not just related to
that it's also related to
filling and
and empowering and adding power to your
identity and so
so a good way to understand it like in
terms of the fall
would be
you know a kind of mysterious idea which
is that
when adam and eve fell
they
fractured human nature
into multiplicity of individuals
and that fracturing brought about a
world of
death because the fracturing happened
fractally it happened
in the human nature going going towards
multiplicity of beings but then in the
human person
is a breakdown of human desires and
human passions and human needs that
now begin to compete with each other and
fragment and break apart but
ultimately
the secret is that this will ultimately
be the filling up of the world as well
so
that this
this fragmentation once it is
gathered back maybe is the best way to
understand it when it's once it's
gathered back then it's actually going
to become a fullness
a fullness which was not there even at
the outset
um
and so
so all right so so so so think about it
you can think about it this way let me
give you a simple example as simple as
examples i can
so you
you put yourself in a new position you
you uh you uh you start a new job
and uh
you've never done it before and so
you have a knowledge you have a moment
of knowledge
where you're you're cast out of the
garden you're put into a position where
things
don't make sense you don't know what it
is and so you
it's frac it breaks down the stuff in
front of you everything looks chaotic
nothing knows what it is and so
so that's painful and it's a kind of
dying
uh but ultimately
once you're able to master that
new reality this new job that you have
to do
and you integrate it then it's it's
actually a fullness
and it's more than you were before you
become more than you were before
and so
yeah but you could so a job is maybe not
the right way to to see it because it's
maybe more like something like uh
like a bad luck you know like you
you end up in a situation you hadn't
planned you know you you've never done
it before you break down on the side of
the road and you've never changed a tire
before and so it's like
yeah pain suffering you look around you
don't know what to do you look at all
these things you look at a jack you look
at a wheel like what is this i don't
know what to do with this and then you
work it out and you suffer and your and
it's painful and once you're done then
that problem that problem that happened
to you at the outset has become an
opportunity to become more
hopefully that makes sense
right
and now everybody's talking about cats
in the chat
yeah yeah youtube and cats huh we
thought that was over but i guess we're
still dealing with that stuff
all right one went from the chat
frederick gopher schmidt asks what's the
symbolism of the laying on of hands and
its connection to the apostleship
um i mean it's it's just action right if
you when you act in the world you act
with your hands so if you're if you're
hammering a nail you're using your hands
pretty much everything you do you do
with your hands and so it's not
completely strange or odd that if you
were going to
to transmit some authority on someone
then you would do it by your hands right
so like you can bless you know a priest
will bless with his hands but like the
idea of like putting your hands on
someone and then speaking
so that
that's how you transfer some kind of uh
some authority or some kind of role
you know
it's just an extension of everything you
do with your hand basically i think is a
way to understand it
um all right so reuben korf in back into
the questions i'm just about to begin
working as an english teacher
and my school has allowed me complete
creativity as regards to novels films to
teach my class
example the text could have really been
in another language just as long as it
has been translated into english
are there any high school age
appropriate novels and films that you
would recommend
that i teach
for their symbolic richness
and resonance and or any particular
books you would recommend for me as a
teacher to help me approach teaching my
classes with a symbolic
hermeneutic
um
i mean if i was you i would i would
teach the classics like i would i would
teach the the old stories that's what i
would do
and so you know
i would have them read a prose maybe a
prose version of the
of uh odysseus
that would be great you know um
that's what i would tend to be to do if
it was you and so in terms of the films
then
i would choose films that have
kind of powerful
symbolic stories in them you know like
i always talk about um
[Music]
the the ghibli studio films i think are
really great you know but even but i
think you can get stuff from popular
fiction
the thing about the thing of the thing
that can be interesting is rather
having a popular fiction movie like a
marvel movie or something but then
surprising people which is how coherent
it is and so for example
studying a a more traditional text like
odysseus and then
showing how some of the some of the
tropes are there as well in um
in these modern movies
you know and so
that's what i would tend to be doing
myself
all right i need to open the door here
guys because i'm running out of air
sorry i'll be right back
it's all right all right
all right so marcus shara says
i became a catechumen on sunday largely
thanked your videos wow that's wonderful
glory to god
um have you ever read anything by the
pragmatists american pragmatists william
james charles sanders pierce they both
defended lives of faith as opposed to
strictly modernist racist worldview
pierce also developed the theory of
icons and symbols i know the peterson
has been influenced by that and i'm
afraid to say that no i have not been
influenced by them and so i don't know
much about about them
sorry
so jeremy feareth asks can you talk
about the symbolism of stoning a person
yeah
is it related to the heap of stones that
jacob and and laban
used to make a covenant with each other
hmm it's definitely related to a heap of
stones i don't know if it's related to
that particular heap of stones i would
have to think about it it's definitely
uh it's definitely related to the
difference between
ordered stones and a heap the difference
this is actually the difference between
a
uh like let's say
an ordered
building and a pile
right sometimes people because they
can't see the difference between
a pile and a
an ordered
group of things they can sometimes get
confused but i think that's what has to
do it it's like burying some someone
under a pile
and a pile is like a disordered thing a
pile is like a
you know a disordered and i it so i
think that's probably what it has to do
with um i'm sure manchu would have way
better insight on this
so corey ford says does god only
ultimately reconcile all beings to
himself or will some forever remained
estranged what's the big picture pattern
at this point i'm generally persuaded by
david billy hart and thomas talbot
following origin gregory et cetera the
ultimate reconciliation
is true
um
i mean if you watch my videos a while
you'll see that i to me i think that
i definitely see that
it all points to
a fullness like it all points to an
ultimate reconciliation
you see it in the words of of christ you
see in the words of saint paul you see
it in
the pattern that's the right there in
sangre of nissan maximus and not just
the things they say like think people
say like sangria has a few sayings that
he has which which suggests that but
it's not saying it's like the very
structure of the life of moses tends to
point to that and the very structure and
say maximus but
the reality is that the tradition that
there is a
that there is a kind of absolute
casting off
uh
a kind of eternal casting off
it's something which is there as well
it's there in the tradition and i think
that it's difficult when people try to
i think there's there's probably a
reason why those two coexist
you know someone told me about because
we have this wonderful homily by saint
john chrysostom on on the pasca in which
there is this very powerful beautiful
image of this idea that all are called
to the feast like all will participate
no matter if you fasted or if you didn't
fast no matter what you did
today is the celebration of the
resurrection all are called to the feast
and there's this powerful image
and then i remember a priest who
reminded me that if you read saint
sanchez saint john's homily on easter
saturday or like the day before let's
say uh
before the resurrection then it's the
it's the other tradition it's really
about
about you know uh suffering and you know
the the suffering brought about by your
own
by your own passions and how
yeah and so and how that is that is a
reality like it's a real thing and so i
tend to just leave that as an aporia
myself and uh
not trying not to resolve it in the
manifest like try not to resolve it in
in a statement because
i think those two traditions are there
for a reason and they're there to kind
of
because there is a reality and this is
something that i've noticed and
you know is that i've noticed
that when people openly advocate for a
kind of universal salvation
they tend to start to dismiss
the
things
they tend to want to swallow the
hierarchy they tend to want to dismiss
the hierarchy and there's a weirdness
that comes with it like there's a kind
of there's there's a kind of strange uh
yeah there's a kind of idea there's a
kind of strangest about that which is
all trying to destroy the world almost
like there's a
tendency to want to destroy traditions
destroy forms as if it's all it all
ultimately doesn't matter you know
people will never say that but there's a
weird attitude that comes with with that
and so i think we rather should be
humble about it and
um
and
see in the story you see in san gregor
see in the words of christ and in the
words of paul like this amazing
this amazing sparkle of this possibility
and the amazing sparkle that you know
ultimately all
will be resolved but also fear
for our own
for our own passions and and see that we
are very far from that and that we need
to uh
we need to take this stuff seriously you
know and so
that's my take on that
um
and so i would never advocate for the
the the universalist position ever
i think it's uh it's dangerous in many
ways so sorry to universe let's watch
this
and uh not sorry at the same time
because i think it's their most
traditional position so all right
so dean dean parker says hi jonathan i
hope all is well
is there much difference between the
platonic forms and the patterns you talk
about in your videos
um and so
there's definitely a relationship
between the two
i think that the more ancient
cosmologies are probably closer to what
i'm talking about than the platonic
forms although i do think that plato is
super helpful and i think that
neoplatonism especially is super helpful
to to to help us integrate all this
together
but
i'm really more like i'm really a lot
older world than that it's like a higher
hierarchies of
of prince of active principalities is is
what i think the world is mostly made of
um that is that these forms are not just
abstract concepts or abstract ideas
that the ideas are
active that their purposes
uh and so that's why sam i think say max
was the confessor gets it so much better
because he joins the notion of forms
with the notion of purpose
and and he kind of
he joins like the notion of forms with
the notion of uh let's say uh
aristotle's final causes you know that
that
that there's a there's an active aspect
there's something which is pushing and
pulling which is bringing things into
into uh into being through through uh
to teleology and so
i think that that might be the
difference
all right so walrus 14 says hi jonathan
i recently stumbled upon a strange music
genre i never heard of before
conservative punk
yeah
um so andy crawford says teaching great
divorce tomorrow uh yeah great divorce
is wonderful like i think
i think the great divorce is a beautiful
book to help us understand
you know the reality of
the all the imagery we have of of
of uh
of damnation you could say and and how
you know i think it's a i think it's a
powerful book for that um
even in dante's inferno there are some
interesting things in dante's inferno
there are some interesting hints about
you know even in hell like there's once
once uh dante asked virgil he asks
he says is it possible
that things will get better for these
these people
after the after the return of christ
and virgil says
you know something like maybe so or
something like that like he hints at the
possibility
you know and so and so it's like i think
that those hints are beautiful and they
can make us
they can make us hope and have have joy
and a secret
kind of
of of hope but i think that we have to
be careful with that
and not make it into dogma and not make
it into
um
a stumbling stone for people around us
that's maybe the best way to say it
all right
all right this made me think about your
discussions on the center still
believing that it's on the margin
and using that false belief to crush the
actual present margin conservative
traditional values are definitely on the
margin now in american society so seeing
conservatism become the new punk makes
some sense however do you think this is
appropriate should those who want a
traditional hierarchy and society act
rebellious in the manner punk's music
calls for
or is being a conservative punk and
oxymoron got less and so
there's ways to be a conservative punk
guys there that's for sure
so we'll do it i'm next okay so next
video the next video that's coming out
is going to be richard rowland's
amazing discussion that i do with him
amazing discussion on symbolism of
groundhog day seriously guys it's
astounding it's really wonderful um but
then after that i'll do a video on uh
on king david on king david
how king david flees uh
king saul and we'll look at the
conservative punk
in that video
all right
so alan di rienzo says in your spare
time can we get a video aimed towards
teenage kids discussing covet media
propaganda social media phone addiction
excessive gaming oh my goodness and any
other relevant current issues our teens
face in this crazy world
i don't know i don't know if that's
gonna happen it's just uh like uh
i don't know can you really see me doing
like the more you know video like a kind
of video
to like help teen kids uh
i don't know that sounds kind of corny i
don't see how i could do it without
being uh
without being corny um
let me think about it okay i need to
think about it because the way you
describe it
it i didn't have a nice image in my head
and i had a
like i had a hello fellow young people
image in my head when when i read your
question so sorry alan you know i
understand that you're struggling
because everyone we're all struggling
with that question certain terms of our
teens you know i you know so it's it's i
understand all right
here we go
so nathan hart jonathan i'm not sure if
you ever spent time in the american
southwest particularly the form of
spanish colonies like new mexico are you
familiar with the traditional art styles
of retavlos and raretos how do you think
to relate to traditional eastern
iconography could they represent a
possible counterfactual to the direction
of western art ended up taking i.e the
decadent art of the renaissance there is
an amazing article on this uh by andrew
gould on the orthodox arts journal who
where he posits
a a
how does he call it he posits a kind of
d taking baroque
and repurposing it towards something
which is closer to traditional
iconography and he tries to show how
indeed there is a
close relationship both in practice and
in the visual style that they end up
taking on which resembles
eastern iconography and that uh
it's really it is it's a really really
great article so look it up it's
definitely worth your time
so white lawrence says what do you think
rcs lewis's flaws as a thinker if any um
i don't know i like c.s lewis i don't
think i
as a thinker i think
he has flaws as a fiction writer
there are some things in those those uh
those narnia books which i don't think
are great but
um as a thinker he's pretty amazing and
he's amazing in the sense that if you
think of
if you think of
it's almost like he's a he's a bomb that
got dropped onto
the kind of western protestant world
it's pretty astounding and he's a bomb
that was able to say things in a way
that
that most um
protestants and evangelicals loved
but that were deeply medieval deeply
deeply medieval and his vision of the
world is deeply medieval and so i think
for sure c.s lewis is a
is a is a definite
possible
turning point or platform or or space of
engagement that could that could help
the the modern world and so i really
appreciate for example paul vander clay
really kind of diving into c.s lewis and
and trying to really uh show people the
power of his writing because it's like i
don't i don't have time and i'm also not
an expert on cs lewis i've read some cs
lewis i haven't read all of it so it's
probably also why i'm sure if i read a
lot of it i might find some things to
criticize but for sure what i've read
about uh
see i've read from cs lewis has been
quite amazing
um
um all right
all right so here we go
next sense okay
jay garcia says hope i hope this makes
sense is irony an angel or a demon it
seems you can't escape irony when you
deconstruct a system kg criticizing
social media from twitter or selling
your marxist book on amazon but there is
also irony that comes from accepting the
system
uh
eg he who loses his life gains it
freedom ins is submission to god you
mentioned satanism it's your irony in
the montero video
but what is its role from a cosmic point
of view
um
so
for sure you can see that i think that
it's
i think that it can be both
uh
i think it has this has to do with like
the flip and the double flip or
something that has to do with like the
upside down and the and the upside down
which turns back and so the difference
between
it has to do with the fool like it has
to do with this turning and the fool and
the idea that
there's a need on the edge to show the
opposite or to show the place where
where the opposite manifests
you know the the contradiction you could
say so
it's like
even let's say in terms of let's say it
takes something like sarcasm you know
sarcasm is important because it shows
you that you could say the same phrase
you could say a phrase and mean the
opposite of what the phrase says that's
pretty amazing think about it think
about saying something sarcastically
means that you say something
but in the if you in the very phrase you
have a statement but what you're
actually using it for
is to say the opposite of that statement
now that's it's pretty powerful it's
powerful because it represents the the
end of meaning
right and so it has that function
um
and so i think that that's why you could
say that satanism is the ultimate irony
right it's the it's it's always it's
done ironically and it's not surprising
that it's unironically because it is in
a way just an inversion of christianity
and it's an inversion of christianity
that people don't even believe they
don't even believe in it it's like it's
all a joke you know
but it's a joke that's ultimately played
on them because
they're embodying it more
by not even believing it not even
believing in it you could say um but
there's a way in which in the story of
christ there's also that right i've
talked about you know the the insane
the insane situation of christ being on
the cross
and having
a sarcastic statement above his head
where it says jesus christ
lord king of the jews which is which
says something straightforward says what
he is
is there to say the opposite
but then ultimately is saying the the
thing
it's ultimately true
right that's what christ does with with
these patterns it's like
right the same with when he is is being
tortured you know they they
dress him up as a
king they mock him they do it to mock
him as lowest
and then ultimately without knowing it
they're actually revealing his true
identity and so it's like
all right curiouser and curiouser
lisa barrett says i hate sarcasm
it's funny because i i i very rarely use
sarcasm though it's true i don't know
why
maybe i do and i don't realize but i
don't think i do
um
actually actually i think lisa
yeah i think i think there is a moment
where you sarcasm think about it now
anyways or whatever all right here well
cure certain cures what's the symbolism
of feeding the five thousand
with five barley loaves and two fish i'm
especially interested in the pattern of
eminence and emergence taking place
within the narrative sequence and so
yeah
this is a great there's a great miracle
to understand
i like to think about this miracle in a
way like
that is that i could explain the miracle
mechanically let's say if i want if you
wanted to you could explain it but it
would be nonetheless be
a
a manifestation of how the world unfolds
and so
so let's say i was a pure materialist i
do believe miracles by the way like you
know
uh
but this is a miracle but i could you
could maybe explain it even mechanically
and it would still be a miracle in the
sense that you can imagine that
christ is christ is there
and he asked he asks people to share
their food
with everybody
and to share it so that
um
we can we can we can feed everybody and
when they do that they ask you know what
they get from that is you know a few
loaves of fish a few loaves and a few
fish
and so
then christ
blesses the the food and then
as he starts to share
this sacrifice that someone
once someone sacrificed his meal so some
young man had food for himself and then
went up and said here i have this food
and he gives it to jesus
and then jesus takes that
and then starts to share it so this the
self-sacrifice of this person
reveals
gathers the real potential
that was there
and so
all of a sudden there's more there's
more bread where does it come from where
where was that bread there was only five
loaves and two fish before there was
implicit bread there was bread hidden
among the people and then now this bread
is being revealed as the self-sacrifice
of this young man and the blessing of
christ is bringing the world together
and then making them trust christ making
them trust each other and therefore
revealing their potential to all around
and so i'm not saying that that's how it
happened but actually thinking about it
in a way that's actually perfectly
explainable in terms of mechanical
causes can help you understand what
christ does and the miracle that he
brings about um but i'm not saying that
that's how christ did it but i'm saying
that you could understand it that way
and it would it would actually help you
understand
the the manner in which christ reveals
the pattern of reality
and how it's related to trust and how
it's related to binding things together
and it's really to self-sacrifice and
all that stuff
all right so brandon burns says when
christ commands the tempest after
sleeping in the boat
and then casts out the demons upon
waking up is this a prefiguration of his
descent and resurrection
when the garrisons beg him to leave
their coast after this happens did they
see him as a monster from the periphery
and so it's definitely a prefiguration
of the resurrection because
i mean there's so many things about it
that's a a prefiguration of the
resurrection because
who's the other person who slept in the
bot in the in a boat
it's jonah jonah is the other person
that's left at the bottom of the boat
and so um you know so it's interesting
it's kind of playing on the story of
jonah where
jonah jonah was sleeping at the bottom
of the boat as everything was raging and
then
as he comes out of the boat
jonah says sacrifice me in order to stop
the the
the boat from sinking basically um and
then christ
plays on that is it at the bottom of the
boat like at the bottom of death and as
he comes out then he masters the waves
himself and so definitely um
and so when the garrisons beg him to
leave their coast after this happens
they see him as a monster i mean i think
they see him as a terrifying being
they seem more like a hero in the old
sense of this like terrifying figure
that is that is awesome
in the original sense of awesome that is
is frightening because he's awesome so
all right so manuel
manuel montiel says what are your
thoughts of the protestant doctrine of
sanctification and its distinction from
theosis it seems the protestant doctrine
of sanctification takes theosis and
divides it into two separate things
sanctification and salvation and then
distinguishes salvation as a sort of
one-time event when saved always saved
and sanctification as a growth towards
god
um
and so i would say it actually really
depends on protestants for sure
you know there are
there are actually some protestants that
that seem to have that have more of a
sense of theosis and
there are also some protestants that
have a more mystical tradition but let's
say something like calvinism for example
at least certain strands of calvinism
that i've encountered they definitely i
had an argument with a um
with a uh
calvinist pastor once which i regret
just because i should never have gotten
into it but nonetheless it happened uh
so i got this argument with uh with a
with a uh calvinist minister and i was
really impressed because he understood
theosis
and
he said that salvation is a moral change
and is not as ontological transformation
and i was surprised because he was
really insisting on this fact he was
insisting on how salvation
is and and in salvation and
sanctification both of them participate
in a moral change in the person it makes
you a better person
but there is no until there is no
going up the ontological ladder there is
no transformation
uh of the being itself
um and i and i was really i was amazed
that he was so clear that he really
believed that and but i also believe
that
why would anybody want that once you
once you have the doctrine of of of
theosis because the doctrine of theosis
the the the the notion of theosis makes
sense of the entire cosmos and say to
make sense of everything because without
it you have this arbitrary god that
creates beings for his glory and then we
are supposed to like be good but we
can't so god makes us good so we can
kind of become good beings so that we
can praise god
and it it's all very
arbitrary and so
in the in the in the doctrine of theosis
you have this very powerful image of a
god that creates his
creatures out of love because he wants
to ultimately be united with them and
that the incarnation is the very impetus
of creation that he wants to be united
with them he wants to transform them and
make them participate in his very being
and it's like that is so beautiful and
powerful and so much fuller and so it to
me was astounding and it's like
there's no way anybody could ever
convince me to go back to that like why
would i ever go back to that world
there's nothing you could say there's no
verse you could quote there's nothing
you could say which would make me leave
uh
the the powerful image of
of of a loving god that exists in love
and that wants to make us one with him
truly truly one with him
as much as possible as saint maximus
says as much as that is possible for a
created being to be god that is what god
wants from us for us that's what that's
his desire that's why he created us and
so he wanted to share us to share in all
his glory he want us to bring us in and
make us participate in
the divine council it's like that's
awesome you know but so you know i don't
know
there's nothing anybody could say to
bring me back to that other place
um sorry
all right so dorothea says
what do you think about the great
resignation
the phenomena that around 40 of young
people are either quitting their jobs or
thinking about it i've seen right-wing
media connecting this to the anti-work
movement but my experience in
southeastern europe is that really a lot
of young people are quitting and it's
because of being overworked underpaid
and just mistreated by an
over-controlling management
is it maybe that in the chaos of the
world people just don't believe that
enduring that will pay off a lot of my
friends say they don't believe there
will be something like pension in 50
years yeah i don't believe that it is
weird that it's happening in very
different places at the same time so
i mean it is it's a disengagement and i
think that you're right i think that the
disengagement has two forms the one of
the disengagement has
one of the disengagements is part of the
notion that you mentioned which is the
idea that in the workplace or in the
indus in industry we see humans as
machines
we treat humans as machines we see them
as machines we see them as as things
that produce things and you so you
measure you have to produce so much you
have to be so efficient you have to make
so many things in such time
uh you know and we compare and we
calculate and we and you're you're uh
you're uh you know and that's
what a job is is basically you're a
human machine and so it's like i
understand why people want to quit that
i understand how people want to leave
that world you're not building you're
not let's say a village that's like
everybody's working together to build
the church or that everybody's you know
working together to to make sure that
the village survives together that
there's a sense of of togetherness and
so if the if the mayor of the village is
a little harsh or a little annoying you
can see that nonetheless they're there
to to make your village thrive but when
you're working from some giant
corporation that doesn't care a lick
about you and that is only there to to
to you know to create like billionaires
and and now trillionaires i guess you
know i can understand why you just
wanted to just like skip out on that i
get it
um but i think there's also the other
part and i think there's also
a kind of draw of the world of leisure
and a world of kind of decadence and a
world of pleasure where we think that
the the purpose of existence is to have
fun and the purpose of existence is to
dilapidate ourselves and to party and to
do all that so it's like imagine those
two worlds facing each other one where
you're either a cog in a machine and
you're like you're just a you're just a
human robot or you are
something like uh like a you know like
an indulgent you know video game playing
porn addicted guy in person it's like
that's the reality that a lot of people
have and so no wonder that people go for
the woke like people go for some cause
like something which makes them feel
like they're participating something
which makes them feel like they're
building something you know and so it's
like i have a lot of sympathy for young
people today
and uh you know and so it's
[Music]
so it's it's our job to to it's our job
to reconnect like it's our job to
try to create participate in things that
are real that's why i say go to church
and i told you like when i say go to
church obviously i do mean go to church
but i by saying go to church i also mean
like
try to be engaged in things and projects
and in in teams and
in groups and you know like whatever it
is co-ops like
whatever it is that you can muster to
create common real common goals in you
know
uh real common projects and goals i
think that's
that's going to help
you know and so
yeah
this
all right so here we go sorry why am i
getting all worked up
man
all right so david franco said jonathan
i've been pondering your discussions of
stories for some time you talk about
different versions of medieval stories
for example a dragon is slayed or is
tamed then slayed et cetera what do you
make of the different accounts the
gospels in protestant discussion just
claim that is what makes the story
authentic but after listening to you i
think there's more to it than that
and in this example different accounts
would be context of peter's recognition
of christ thank you
so i think i think the best way to
understand the four gospels is rather to
understand it as the multiplicity which
comes which necessarily comes out of
unity and so there's a there's a manner
in which we don't find
the finality in the multiplicity and
this is right the mistake of of science
it's in general
you know and so
we actually find
the unity in the unity in the place
where these things are
brain come together and that there's a
there's actually a
power
there's a mr mysterious power in the
ambigua which is right which is what the
mysterious power in the places where the
texts actually don't uh connect that
they if you look at the two traditions
they can probably reveal something to
you that is
probably higher than reason you could
say that is like a kind of uh antinomia
antinomial thing like a
an aporia which reveals a higher mystery
um
but
i think that that's rather the way to
understand it and so you can understand
like the four aspects of christ
you know and that's what people
traditionally i think people have
understood it that you know
you know the gospel of saint john is the
higher shows the kind of more let's say
spiritual aspect and uh
and the gospel of uh of of
now get them i'm getting them confused
and so one is the more royal aspect
um
and then the more human aspects uh yeah
so the the gospel of matthew the more
human aspect the gospel say mark the
more royal
et cetera et cetera and so i think that
that's probably the
the best way to see it uh you know
so hopefully that makes sense sorry hope
i didn't confuse those which is possible
so christian christ asks hello jonathan
can you talk about the relationship
between christopher and the virgin mary
thank you
oh man
so
uh all right so you could say that um
i've talked about the two mary's maybe
that's the best way to understand it
i've talked about the two mary's maybe a
few times
in these talks where there's a there's
there's a tradition in the west
of you could say something like the two
mary's so there's the there's mary the
mother of god and then there's mary
magdalene so there's the [ __ ] and the
virgin
and in the orthodox church we don't have
mary magdalene because mary magdalene is
really it's really a composite figure in
the in the way the west has developed it
and i think it's totally fine i think
it's useful but in the in the east we
have uh some area of egypt and so you
have some area of egypt and you have
saint mary the mother of god so you have
the [ __ ] and the virgin the saturated
one the confused the hybrid the the the
external one and then the hidden one the
secret one the pure one and there are
two aspects of the lower world you could
say two aspects of earth
best way to see that you can see the
earth as pure untouched
and uh pure potential and you can see
the earth as
chaotic waves uh
mixture
uh lack of lack of identity chaos you
know all that stuff so so those are two
aspects of the lower world you could say
uh and uh and so saint christopher is
definitely the
on the side of
of uh same area of egypt you could say
you know
and there's a sense and this is the
mystery there's a sense in which
the so you could say that the mother of
god carries christ
in in the the
carries christ in the the manger in the
secret place
uh and saint christopher
crosses christ over into the strange
land but there's a way
there's a way in which the virgin mary
kind of contains both to ins in her and
i'm not saying the virgin mary is a
monster and all this stuff there's a way
in which the the virgin mary contains
both aspects of mary because she also
carries christ to egypt
uh and
also
yeah
so because she is the right hand
i've talked about this before like the
the
the right side
contains the it's like a
stand-in for the center you could say
and so the virgin mary contains both
aspects
but mostly in the in the pure form but
she also is capable of going to egypt
you could say
all right uh without losing without
man i can't believe i'm going to say
this so she's able to go to egypt
without the suspicion that the pharaoh
took her like he
strangely might have taken abraham's
wife
okay does that make sense hope that hope
that makes sense so she's able so she
does have she has saint christopher in
her but she's not
just saying christopher she has
something which makes her
all
right let's go on the ledge with these
these answers
all right
all right so kevin patterson says
so how can a material body be feminine
to its masculine unseen spiritual
identity while at the same time its
external physicality is masculine to its
feminine hidden interior identity of the
being
how can the material body be feminine
to its masculine unseen spiritual
identity while at the same time its
external physicality is masculine
to its feminine hidden or interior
identity of the being
not sure i understand that kevin i'm
sorry i'm not sure i'm not sure the way
you ask a question
is the proper way to understand it maybe
that's why i don't understand it because
i'm not sure the way you structure it is
the right it's like you're asking me to
how is it that this is the way it is and
maybe the way you're describing it is
not the best way to describe it i would
say
um
so
yeah sorry man i'm not sure
all right
joe kelly says a major flaw in agape
from my perspective is that it leads to
reciprocal narrowing
of self-sacrificing love until you get a
combinatorial explosion when deciding
what to sacrifice for
got a lot of john revaki in that for
that sense here symbolism and emergence
is what i see taking over society when
that desolation occurs and we lose our
ability to reflect or aspire the
question is in a symbolic world how do
people ascend symbolically and avoid
alienating or leaving behind persons at
lower levels of understanding
so major flight again for my perspective
is that it leads to reciprocal narrowing
of self-sacrificing love so you get a
combinatorial explosion when deciding
what to sacrifice for
yeah i'm not sure i'm not sure again i'm
not sure i follow what you mean
um
so
why does it why does it do that so so
okay so
the way that you should let's say the
way that
the things you should sacrifice too
they're they they are objective
right
the the highest things you should
sacrifice too they are
truth beauty
uh love
um that's what the things you should
sacrifice to their god god is what you
should sacrifice to
and then you know you could say that in
terms of virtues and you you you
sacrifice things to acquire the virtues
now
now of course
there are more arbitrary things that you
sacrifice too let's say you're get let's
say you sacrifice in order to get a job
you sacrifice things uh in order to
to do certain projects you know you you
end up having to to eliminate things you
want to become a good basketball player
you have to focus on that and so
so so those are more arbitrary but those
will ultimately only be fruitful if you
have those higher
goals
if you don't then
those lower goals that you sacrifice to
will become something like idols
and uh
and then they they so
so what what happens and this is
this is something that i can can't
explain to you but what happens is that
when you focus on the higher things
the lower things they actually just
they just appear on your horizon
they they shine
and then there isn't a combinatorial
explosion
it actually it's like uh it's like you
see the lover
right you see the person you care for in
the crowd shining brightly and then you
you move towards that um
and so
that's what actually what happens
um and so if you're in a position where
you're
in a
position of combinatory explosion where
it's like you don't know what to do
right what job should i have what what
person should i date what should i what
should i do what should i how should i
what should i look like what should my
style be or whatever kind of question
you can
ask yourself in in a life i would say
the solution to that is to aim higher
that's a solution and if you
you act it with the desire for truth for
example if you act with the desire for
higher things for beauty for
for love then
then those lower things will be given to
you how about that how about if i use
the actual words of christ you know it's
like search the kingdom of god
and all those things will be given to
you you know they're not they're not
there won't be an ex ex it won't be a
combinatorial explosion so i hope i
understand the sense of your question
maybe i don't even understand the sense
of your question
but uh hopefully that was useful for
some people nonetheless
all right mirohamad jonathan do we exist
before we were born or does our
existence start at the womb or after we
are born
what is the orthodox take on this
so my understanding of the orthodox take
on this is that uh that we are that we
that life starts at conception
that is the orthodox take on that and
that there is no
it is fuel futile to think that there is
a previous
existence in the sense that we think of
time
uh that that our our existence as human
is born in time and space
and so are we know
we are insoled when we are conceived
um and so you know we could say
something like you exist as an
as an idea in the mind of god you know
you could say something like that that's
i think that's appropriate but um but
the way we understand is that as humans
we we are meant to to be to exist a
conception
yep so that makes sense
i hope that makes sense i mean
all right noah says when the kingdom of
israel splits in two from a symbolic
perspective why is the division so
lopsided
is it trying to show the imbalance of
our spending way more time in exile in
ireland worship and attention
than we do in proper worship and
relation to god um i think i think it
has to do with with the notion of the
remnant
i think that's probably the best way to
understand it which is that
let's say if something breaks down
one of the aspects will become the seed
for the next world
uh that's probably the best way to
understand it
something like an arc
and so i think that's why that's why
it's like all of israel falls except for
judah and a little bit of a little bit
of others but it's mostly judah you know
i think that's what it has to do with
all right anders vralstad hello what
symbolic insight is told in the story of
lazarus death and is his sister marta
important
for this symbolism
um
definitely
i mean definitely both mary and marta
are important in the story of lazarus
like all the times that
christ encounters them
it's kind of revealing
it's kind of revealing this the same
thing
um
and marta is something like
something like the the
the desire for control the desire to to
or the desire to to think that
we've got this the desire to get lost in
the causalities to get lost in the all
these mechanical stuff all these these
lower causalities
um
and i think that that's usually what
what what she represents you know
and then mary is more
attention and how attention precedes
those other things and so
mary attends and marta is so that's why
marta
when christ arrives three days you know
after lazarus is dead
she's like this doesn't make sense like
this causality
is doesn't make sense like if you had
done this it would have been done this
and if you you know if you hadn't done
this then this would have happened um
and
and there's
and christ is trying to help her see
beyond that and to see that
all these little things they're
dependent on these bigger things they're
dependent on him ultimately but they're
dependent on these higher
things
you know
and so
yeah
that's the way i see it
all right alyssa says hi jonathan what
is the symbolism of inverted perspective
in iconography
i think someone's asked this before a
few times
uh all right so i can tell you what the
theory is
though this is this comes from um
pavel uh florensky wrote a book called
econostasis which has some powerful
things in it but one of his theories was
this inverted perspective thing and the
idea was that the icon was like inverted
perspective where instead of the
the vanishing point being out in the
icon
out in the image like you know how the
image goes out into a vanishing point
that in an icon the vanishing point was
you basically so the the icon was open
and that it was pointing towards you and
you were like the the point um and he
used i think if i remember correctly he
used um
uh trinity icon as as one of the types
of this
and um you know i mean it's an
interesting idea
the the problem with that is that it
doesn't work out it's like icons don't
have inverted perspective or they
sometimes have inverted perspective but
most of the time they they don't like if
you if you try to work out the
perspective of icons it's actually
multiple perspectives and um
i think if you're interested in that
i think that aiden hart writes a
wonderful little article about that on
multiple perspectives which is in his um
in his book on uh
icon and fresco painting and so he talks
about multiple perspectives and tries to
to see how these different perspectives
have might have different meanings and
including inverted perspective saying
that inverted perspective is kind of
part of that just one aspect of these
different perspectives um
so there's a lot of discussion about
this prospective question in icons and
people tend to disagree a lot about that
all right so chandler turner says kanye
recently released a video for his song
heaven and hell which features imagery
heavily influenced by classical art the
most prominent of these is the
illustration by gustav concho 34 of the
paradiso video ends with the recreation
of john martin's the fall of babylon if
you've seen the video i'd like to hear
your thoughts on it if not i would be
interested to hear your elaboration on
the symbolism of those famous pieces and
so
um
yeah i saw the video it was for my
favorite song by the way on the album uh
and so i saw the video
there are a few things which
disappointed me i think the first thing
that disappointed me was that it was an
ad for his his his hoodies it was an it
was an ad for easy uh the yeezy brand at
the gap which i was a little bit like
what you made a song about
heaven and hell and it's an ad for your
for the for the hoodies that are that
are um
displayed in the in the video i thought
that was a bit pushing it's like i'm
nothing against selling things like i
sell things this is fine with that but i
thought that was a little pushing it
um but i did i mean the basic imagery
that i found interesting was of course
this duality you could say which is that
he was giving two possibilities which is
one the possibility of ascending and the
second was the was the possibility of
conflict and the breakdown of society
and see that's why i think he chose
those two images and was contrasting
them to each other which is basically
saying you've got these two choices
either you go up and you ascend towards
god or you will end up in a situation
where civilian civilization is going to
uh to collapse and babylon is going to
fall apart so i think that that was the
basic um
the basic idea in that and it's it's
still impressive i like it's an
impressive video
um
it's complicated that he showed that
he's hiding people's faces all the time
it's a very complicated thing
you know
i'll tell you something about kanye
which i was wondering if i was going to
make a video about it but i might as
well just talk about it now um
so
kanye did uh
he did a concert recently with uh what's
his name the other rapper look at me i'm
just such a boomer
um anyways he did this concert he did he
did a live concert uh with drake that's
his name drake so he did a live concert
with drake and it was weird because i
was i'd come back from some some meeting
or something and it started super late
it started like 11 30 or midnight and i
didn't know and i caught it on youtube
before we went to bed and i ended up
staying up until two in the morning
which was horrible but i ended up
watching the whole concert and uh
it was really interesting
it was interesting like
when you watch kanye's performance
because it really like if you want to
see like the
the difficulty of
if you watch my video on the sower on on
the parable of the sower you can see the
difficulty that someone like him is in
and so he was doing a concert and he was
singing his songs
and most of his songs are insanely
vulgar sacrilegious they're they're
horrible the words are horrible and so
here he was doing a concert singing his
own songs and then he was
he would sing and then he would stop and
he wouldn't sing certain phrases
sometimes certain words but sometimes
not saying the bad words doesn't matter
because you cannot say the f word but
the entire structure of your sense is so
wretched that even if you don't say the
bad word it doesn't matter because the
whole sentence is horrible and so he
doesn't say he doesn't say the words
then he's like
and then sometimes it's him but in a
recording saying the words but then he
doesn't say it
and then sometimes he would give in and
he would actually say the words and say
the kind of darker things
and i swear if you look at his face
during the whole time
it's like you see someone who is morally
struggling like you can see it in his
expression that he is struggling to hold
on he's holding on by his fingernails
and he's not he doesn't know what to do
you know and it's like and i get it's
like his wife divorced him and
everything is falling apart around him
and it's like you can see that that's
what's going on and so it's
it's actually kind of sad it's like a
sad if you watch it and you see what's
happening it's very sad to watch it
happen and it's understandable because
he had so much it's like imagine you
have so much power and so much
fame and so much influence
and then it's like no matter what you
say no matter what you do people are
gonna love you like no matter you could
say the worst there so there's almost
nothing you can do anymore like you've
already loved the worst supposed you
know
orange man in in in culture and not and
sit and you and then you put out an
album and it's like number one platinum
album
in america and so it's like you've done
it all and you can say anything it's
like man can you imagine being in that
position it would be horrible like it
would be so dangerous so anyway i was
sad watching that i mean i was impressed
because it was i mean i like kanye west
i like his music but i was like i was
sad to watch him struggle morally
because of his baggage like because of
his earth that he's carrying with him
and that he has to
he has to he has to kind of deal with it
and so it's
there are a few people like for example
like i don't know if you guys know that
about roosh v who converted to uh
orthodoxy like he actually unpublished
his books which is really impressive he
unpublished his books he he closed down
the forums he basically he he basically
stripped his old world in order to have
nothing left and so it's like that's
impressive because that can lead to
you know that then you've plowed the
earth more and there's more room for the
seed to grow but man
kanye i was feeling feeling bad for him
ain't that why should i feel bad for him
he's
yeah he
all right so here we go
so matthew brandon asks okay this
confuses me to no end
matthew 12 43 when an unclean spirit is
gone out of a man he walketh through dry
places he can rest and findeth none when
he saith i will return into my house
from once i came out and when he is come
he findeth that empty swept and
garnished then goes he and taketh with
himself seven other spirits more wicked
than himself and they enter in and dwell
there and the last state of that man is
worse than the first why would an
unclean spirit seek dry places
if that is order in biblical cosmology
why worse than before i mean it feels
like we should just be happy with the
one imp and not risk seven
um
yeah that's a good question all right so
think about it this way think about it
that okay so think about it like the
world is made of attention or the world
is made of worship is what i mentioned
before and so
it's not it's never enough to get rid of
bad habits
if you try to just get rid of bad habits
it's gonna do this and so
what you need to do is you need to
replace bad habits with good habits
but but so asceticism on his own on its
own is not sufficient so think about so
like for example you read in the church
in the fathers and if you're orthodox
you'll hear every single priest say the
same thing they'll say something like
during lent
there's no point in fasting if you don't
pray if you don't pray and you fast
you're in danger you're in spiritual
danger actually
because you're removing the things that
usually kind of fill up your life
but you're not replacing them with
something ordering things properly
you're just trying to empty the space
but that's not how it works like it's
gonna fill back up and so that's the
idea in this parable it's like
so you lead you you chase the spirit out
of you
but if you don't fill the house with
with a family
if you don't fill the house with with
love if you don't fill the house with
things that are worthy
then
not only is the spirit gonna come back
it's gonna come back seven times more so
this is not this is really like very
simple like
everybody has experienced something some
of this to some extent like think about
a diet think about think about think
about a diet somebody goes on a super
strict diet and then it's super strict
and super strict and super strict then
all of a sudden finds themselves eating
a tub of ice cream you know at midnight
or whatever it's like that's what it's
talking about it's talking about
how
you have to be careful when you try to
get rid of the demons if you don't if
you don't redirect your attention to
something productive
then you're gonna fall worse than before
and everybody knows someone like that
right it's like a drug addict who goes
who's or someone who's an alcoholic who
who becomes clean and then
if they man if they fall off that wagon
they're gonna fall
like they're gonna fall deep it's gonna
be worse than before because
yeah so how'd that make sense
but in terms of if you're the dry places
it's just wilderness so it goes out into
the wilderness into the desert right
just like the egyptian just like the
israelites were out in the desert and so
the desert
is something like uh you know it
has to do with with the wild wild areas
the areas that are not that don't have
name the areas that aren't that aren't a
home that aren't uh part of civilization
so you know that's where the demons go
and then the
circle you know and then whoa
all right
this is lasting longer than usual
i'm interacting too much with the chat
now i'm joking just joking guys
all right there you go janet horseman
says how would you understand a social
contagion from a spiritual perspective i
have teenagers and a good half of their
friends have come out as trans
non-binary bisexual i've talked to them
about this and how this is a social
contagion but to better explain the
phenomena to them i would like to know
this as the social contagion spreads
does it gain body and strength in a
spiritual way
do the people under its spell give it
more power and is it time to move to the
jungle
um
um
so yeah i mean definitely and so you can
understand it as a as a as
principalities right it's so you have
these principalities that are trying to
to manifest they want body you know
so
so these these these weird wild demons
they want body and so they
they want to they that's how they exist
so you can understand it as fashion
uh
something like fashion you can
understand it as all kinds there's all
kinds of ways you can understand it
where
there's a way in which this is not
negative that could also be positive
which is that
you can also do something like this in
the army for example where you
you set people under a certain principle
and then they people fall in line and
they start to manifest the will of that
of that thing and so but this is now
just for wilder principalities where
people kind of fall under and in and
there's also a normal desire
to
give like if you if you are under the
spell of some principality then you also
want to
gain more body for it you know because
you know or at least intuitively you
know that that's how it will survive um
and so
so this is something which has been
definitely happening you know and so
it's there's a there's a relationship
between
uh
fashion narrative all of these things
are making this uh exacerbated at this
moment
so
i hope that helps a little bit
so so he's asked it's a gain body and
strength in a spiritual way it gains
body in a in a in a more embodied way
but then it gains authority in a
spiritual way that is it has more reach
and it has more hold on the way the
world is
is kind of uh manifesting itself but
these patterns are not arbitrary so it's
like there are some patterns which will
will be limited in the whole they can
have because they are
self-devouring patterns they don't
they're not fruitful ultimately they're
kind of parasitical and so
so let's say this pattern
could never be as strong as the pattern
of a man and a woman
having children and raising them it just
it just can't or it can but it as it
does that as it
as it
be gains more power it's going to be
actually
it's going to be releasing the things
that hold society together it's going to
be moving towards a kind of
fragmentation because
because of its very nature you know
right
so drew mcmahon asked are the only two
choices god or nihilism
i mean ultimately maybe but not
not in uh
like not in uh
and in a more
everyday way no because you know there's
there's a forms of
idolatry you could say
which are not exactly nihilism which are
kind of illusions of of absolute of
absolute meaning
um
and then there's also a form which is
maybe the opposite of idolatry which is
of god bringing us closer to him through
secondary goods and so the secondary
goods can also be
a manner we move towards god and so you
can you can for example
uh
let's say
not fully
know that you're moving towards god or
not fully realize it or not fully
realize the the
implications of that uh but are rather
moving towards these secondary goods but
god is using those secondary goods to
kind of pull you along the way um but
then also the like i said you can also
see those secondary goods as as the god
in themselves and then so it's like
someone who's chasing after money
is not a nihilist
he's wrong right he's wrong he worships
mammon or whatever but he's not a
nihilist um so but ultimately it ends it
ends in nihilism that is if we go down
the path of just these secondary goods
then the goods tend to devolve where at
first people want
you know higher goods and then they just
want to get off and then they just want
to die right it's like
there's there's a devolving of the of
the good let's say
all right
all right harry fisher says hi jonathan
why does christ say that we shouldn't
swear by anything but let our yes be yes
and our no be no
yes
please have a follow-up on your last
convo with john vervicky yeah i know i
should i keep it's like every other day
i'm like i need to write a message to
john and then
my days are so full of emails and
meetings and
and like dealing with the logistics of
god's dog and like doing all this stuff
like oh man yeah
so but yes yes i will definitely do that
i need to i need to free myself up more
just to have more mental space
um
so why does christ say we should swear
about anything
let our yes be yes and our no be no and
so
i think this is that i think this has
something to do with the
a kind of problem of idolatry like i
think that's what it has to do with i
think that what was going on
in the time of christ is that people
would swear on different things and that
they would use that as if the truth was
dependent
on the truth wasn't higher than these
secondary goods and so it's like
the truth is higher
think about it this way so the truth is
higher than the temple the truth is
higher than
the the steps of the temple and the
truth is higher by these different
things in the temple but people would
make their truth dependent on
things that are lower than it and so i
think what christ is saying is like
truth is above all of these like truth
is above all that these other things
which are good but that that you know
there isn't a hierarchy of truth it's
not like if you swear by something
smaller then you then there's less truth
in there but if you swear it's like it's
like someone you know we see that in
movies too sometimes it's like people
say like i swear on my mother right and
it's like okay so if you would have
sworn on that turtle then
then maybe i don't believe you but it
but if you swear on your mother then i
believe you because truth is dependent
on the thing you on the thing you uh you
swear by so i think that that's that's
that's what's going on there but i but
ultimately i don't think that there is a
i don't think that there's also anything
wrong with the idea for example of uh
if you see you know the idea of like
let's say putting your hand on the bible
in order to
to swear um
you know
i think it's mostly in that case it's
mostly like to help you remember
the importance of what you're doing and
that you know you
take it seriously like this isn't uh
um
so i think that's what he's saying
ultimately
all right dan christopher which
christian apologist and atheist would
you like to best see in a debate
love you on the rationality rules even
if you may have found the conversation
painful um
i don't know i don't like debates
i don't i don't like watching debates i
do sometimes like i've watched a few
debates but it's like i really don't
like watching debates because i
i feel like it's just to people locked
in their position and and usually
there's no budgeting nobody budges
nobody moves um
but
i would definitely
like let's i would definitely love
to see a discussion
between uh david bentley hart and john
vervicky
and i know some people are trying to
make that happen and i don't know why it
hasn't happened yet because i would love
to see that i think that would be really
interesting because i do think that dave
bentley hart's uh
uh
capacity to understand the role of
consciousness
is super strong you know and i think
that john's working out of of questions
of of of of uh
emergence and emanation and these these
relationships i think it could be a
super interesting discussion i hope that
happens
lynn holland says are there any symbolic
links between the canadian trucker
protests and historic or biblical events
i mean
you guys you haven't seen the meme it
was pretty amazing the wall of jericho
meme where'd you there's someone sent me
this like it was actually
the clown world pepe you know whatever
that that figure is who is honking his
nose and you could see the uh the tribe
going around the walls of jericho you
know honking their blowing their
trumpets and the walls falling down i
thought that was pretty cool because
that definitely what it looks like you
know there's also you know
the truckers there
and it's it's it's all very symbolic
like the whole trucker thing because
from the very beginning of this i
remember when they started putting in
all these mandates and stuff
they shut down the economy the whole
economy for a while but the first thing
they reopened guess what it was it was
construction and of course they never
stopped to transport and so i was like
all right they at least they got that
right it's like don't scratch the bottom
of the world folks don't scratch the
regular people if you do that you don't
understand what's down there you don't
understand that the truckers the
construction workers all the the people
right in the marxist sense like in the
real marxist sense the workers the
people they're what the world is holding
on so you got to be really careful when
you poke at those people because if you
poke at that it's going to
it's going to jump up and it's going to
come get you so it's like it's
interesting that it's truckers because
truckers are saying christopher
basically they're the transporters
they're the ones that move between
borders they're the psycho pumps you
know they're the in-between characters
and so it's like by attacking the
truckers
they were the truckers were able to kind
of awaken
uh
something which didn't have body yet
you know a grumbling that didn't have
body and so it was like there's the body
that image of the truck it's like
you know there's something in the
culture about a truck that is very
powerful and represents the common man
and so if you scratch at that you might
be surprised at what comes up
and uh so it's interesting and it's and
it's and it's inevitable and it's
pathetic to watch our government you
know just right away to scream out all
the epithets and
and it's interesting it's super
interesting because if you didn't think
kobet was political before i hope you
know now because i hope that somehow
magically being able to relate anything
which contradicts
the the state mandates with uh with like
racism and misogyny the way trudeau did
it i mean it's just revealing how
political this is how political it was
at the outset and how it is a a
political agenda towards certain goals
um
so if you didn't think that before
trudeau saying that his that the people
who were resisting medical mandates
are his ideological and political
enemies and moral enemies
bringing in racism and misogyny and all
the woke uh
all the woke speaking points
yeah well it's political and it was it's
been from the beginning so
yeah
all right jeff dunlop says the sabbath
the center or the margin
it definitely has more to do with the
margin
um but it also has something to do with
the the place in which the
the the seed secretly appears in the
in the margin or secretly appears in the
potential like where
the naming stops the work stops
and then
the the seed is secretly coming down
into that to restart the world and so
that's why it has to do with
also christ in the tomb
you could say
um
so i think that's the best way to
understand it but there's definitely an
aspect of the sabbath which has to do
with the margin for sure material i
think showed that without any shadow of
a doubt in his book i mean man
um and so jason says what is the
symbolism of the ronin i think i
answered that from the chat i mean the
ronin is a is
is a warrior that is no longer attached
to
the the is no longer attached to the
traditional authority
someone who has all the
all the training of of of the hierarchy
but
for some reason is no longer
attached to it anymore
so that's the ronin
it's a good way to to end there isn't it
so everybody thanks for your attention
and uh
thanks to uh to lisa
and i don't know if brad was there i
didn't see is brad there
well whoever was there
as a moderator thank you
and uh
yeah i'll talk to you very soon and uh
thanks everybody for your support and
lisa i'm sorry you're tired i know for
you it's super super late and so sorry
about that so everybody bye-bye
good night